from the new york post covid origen's
report says it's plausible virus leaked
from muhanlab
that's it
that's that's that's the origins report
can't tell us the origins
the new york post reports
an unclassified summary of the us
intelligence community's report on cover
19 says it's plausible the virus leak
from a lab in wuhan and that it might be
genetically engineered but investigators
remain divided i suppose at the very
least this you know now when the media
says it's a conspiracy theory
that it's a genetically modified lab
leak or something you can be like well
they said maybe
i'll take maybe right well i mean maybe
it means you can at least discuss it for
a year it was you know oh you went you
you went to the woodshed they took you
to which i beat you up a little bit
maybe maybe suspended you maybe banned
you for talking about something they
went after members of congress you know
yeah
that's well that's so extreme we
mentioned this in a little bit dave
rubin got suspended like a week before
they announced booster shots for saying
booster shots were coming so so dave's
tweeting like they're gonna have booster
shots twitter suspends him and then like
a week later the new york times is like
booster shops shots have been announced
i think with dave it looked like he had
a lot of evidence showing that it was it
probably would happen and he i don't
know exactly what happened but i imagine
he said it it is going to happen and
that's like crossing a line saying that
it's evident and that it looks like it
is very likely is very different than
saying it is but journalists have been
doing this for basically the history of
journalism saying hey we've got sources
saying that this is going to happen i
was talking about this downstairs
you're not allowed to criticize the
world health organization or the cdc
basically by these social media
companies but then
new york times can run a story they did
they did a story at the end of 2019
right right at the end of the year about
the world health organization they said
one of them one of the givens of the
world health organization is that they
want you to keep open borders in the
middle of a pandemic which i think
ordinary people would go well that's
nuts but they they said oh it's this way
but then they dug into it it turns out
there's absolutely no scientific reason
for it it's simply their agenda to keep
the borders open
now
why we do this well because we're
supposed to listen to the sciency people
at the world health organization well
now the funny thing is
you know uh
and we'll we'll give we'll give youtube
it's it's uh it's it's peace
in in all of the horse dewormer stories
you know it's the craziest thing seeing
every single outlet refer to ivermectin
as horse medicine because it's like
don't they give ibuprofen the dogs like
don't they you know what i mean so the
issue is and for you youtube uh that
i've amazing isn't fda approved there
are some studies going on right now but
it is not fda approved for treatment in
covid but it's also not horse medicine i
mean it technically is but it is fda
approved for certain uses like skate
like topical scabies and i think you
know general dewormer stuff the crazy
thing is how the the media is walking in
lockstep they're all saying horse
medicine
it's in a version of horse medicine but
it's also in other things
i mean like medicine we give antibiotics
to horses too yeah it doesn't make them
horse antibiotics right right right
right yeah but how the how the media is
treating it this way how like we have to
even be careful bringing it up because
youtube is sitting there with the thing
like there's somebody at youtube right
now with their finger over the band
button it's shaking and they're like
just
press the button
that's how excited they are to ban us
well they're excited to ban everybody
who dares oh wait you said the wrong
thing i interviewed uh dr zevzalenko
and he got
documents restricted by google docs now
if that is not
1984-ish oh you've got stuff you can't
share them to other human beings even
though you wrote them and they involve
documents that you sent to you know
to world leaders but you can't share
them to other human beings because
they're locked out
i mean that that is there was a um
i think bit shoot was banned like
twitter had banned links to bit shoot
yeah or i think they still do it gives
you a warning and there was one thing i
tweeted about i can't remember what it
was but it was like if you tried to
tweet it it'll give you an error
and so they don't even say they censored
you they're just like oops
site's broken that's all it is and then
you're like this one link remember when
facebook banned minds
yes yeah yeah and you couldn't send a
message a facebook message with
minds.com in the message or it would be
like this
i can top that there are people who are
banned on facebook
not that they're not allowed to be on
facebook you cannot send their websites
by messenger on facebook they they
literally will not be able to send we
ran across it was a dentist a friend of
mine was trying to go to uh out in
arizona and like wow i can't she was
trying to send me the the link to the to
the dentist but he does some holistic
health
and
couldn't couldn't do it they were at the
hunting uh group in dallas their their
website was banned on facebook even
though it didn't violate any facebook
rules the facebook you know
authoritarians who don't like hunting
banned them so so
you know looking back to the the report
which tells us literally nothing you
know the covet origins report you are
basically saying that at least this
allows us to talk about it now right
because before it was like if you
brought this stuff up you're a
conspiracy theorist you risk getting
banned or censored but now that the
intel community is saying maybe we
should be safe right right we're not
going to ban it i think i think well i
mean see the thing is they want to ban
us that's the problem so since you've
got rule sets that are designed to
restrict anything they don't like then
the people who enforce them are people
who restrict anything they don't like
and then the people you appeal to are
the people who restrict anything you
don't like it's kind of set up and of
course you get the fact checkers who are
just evil and moronic and they will also
restrict anything they don't yeah well
you know the thing about fact checking
is
all of these organizations that do
fact-checking that go to the pointer
institute so that on facebook they can
remove you
why don't conservatives set up fact
checking organizations here's why
because the fact i just i've had people
ask us to do it because the fact
checking network can also remove you so
you could spend hundreds of thousands of
dollars hiring people setting up uh the
operation it's very tedious if you start
fact checking cnn cnn's going to call
the pointer and they're going to pull
your authority and then you're off and
that's it you're done because they
control they they control the whole game
and what happened was a whole bunch of
journals got laid off back after 2008 so
they came up and they journalists hate
the fact that people use what are called
you know alternative facts
and so they basically came up with a way
to game the system they
now control the facts even though most
of the time what they're doing is just
narrative
yeah they don't care that oh well we
think your narrative is wrong you need
to include 60 more paragraphs yeah i got
fact checked by lead stories uh actually
it was it was okay so here's what
happened i tweeted out something about
epstein's plane and like bill clinton or
something like that and i don't remember
the exact tweet but everything i said
was factually correct
someone screen grabbed it and posted it
to facebook and then lead stories said
it was it was fake this this this tweet
is false information and so i looked up
i i saw the tag on my tweet screenshot
it i didn't post it and then it said
false information here's why i clicked
it went to their story which confirmed
every single thing in my tweet was
correct when i called the guy from the
company he was irate and yelling
and he was like i refuse to change it
and his argument was basically that the
way it was phrased in the tweet could
give the wrong impression and i said the
impression is irrelevant when my facts
are all correct what someone assumes
based on reading the tweet is irrelevant
i didn't say what you're accusing me of
saying i guess he was accusing me of
saying something like bill clinton went
to epstein island or something which i
didn't say i can't remember exactly what
the tweet was
and then instead of instead of taking
down the fake fact check he left it up
but put you know like partially
incorrect or something like that
so
they can take a a fact and then call it
fake news and false information and then
explain on their end that well it is
technically true but we just want to
provide clear you know clarification so
now when you get hit on facebook and
facebook strips your monetization
that's that's the end result well and
what they do is their favorite is the
context you know oh you don't have
enough context well by that definition
the entire freaking world doesn't have
enough context encyclopedia britannica
doesn't have enough context because oh
you didn't include this book full of
information about afghanistan or those
27 books about you know uh
you know pick your topic calculus oh
well there's not enough information
calculus in there so you need to add
more context we got hit by politifact
for re-running a cdc chart okay so not
doing anything controversial here we
re-ran a cdc chart linked to a story
about it and that story linked back to
the cdc
politifact
gave us a fact check and gave us sort of
like the trifecta of fact checks they
said okay well we lacked context but
then they called it partly false but
then he put a big you know huge red
capital letters false on our chart and
so we challenged that they of course
ignored it so what we did we got more
than 40 conservative organizations
together and sent an obnoxious letter to
the international fact-checking network
and said you got to pull their pull
their your card they are not fair we've
the media research center has tracked
more than 50 examples since 2019 where
they've been out of control yeah and we
didn't really think they would do it but
so now that's got to be the narrative
every time politifact does another lousy
fact check people
you know more than 40 organizations said
this organization should lose its
fact-checking ability do you see when
they uh i can't remember which
organization it was they flagged the cdc
itself as false news yeah
yeah so on facebook a link to the cdc it
was an article from the cdc where they
said that they were changing they were
encouraging new uh testing for covid
and so these facebook fact checkers
flagged cdc.gov as fake news
and you know the funny thing is
when i so there's there's people you can
reach out to at facebook if you're uh
one of the the better men in the
privileged elites like we all are here
i'm kidding in a sense like
but the reality is in this world if you
have a show and you have followers then
all of a sudden there's someone to talk
to at facebook but the regular people
they're they're kick to the gutter so i
know i i have the contact emails i have
the connections and they said when you
get fact checked on facebook it's not us
it's those third-party companies and i
argued
facebook has
given special privileged access that is
not public accommodation
to these people so you're effectively
outsourcing facebook's role in fact
checking to third parties i would argue
that it's still facebook's
responsibility for defamation if
facebook is going to uh if if there is
going to be a box that says fake
information over my post and that is not
true as a statement of fact saying what
i put was false information
then i think facebook and that company
are responsible facebook said screw you
it's them do something about it so you
effectively have to just go after these
fact checkers and sue them for
defamation and the reality is if they
called a cdc chart fake false
information that's not an opinion that's
a statement of fact you gotta sue you
gotta sue for defamation and and of
course you know
these organizations who pays them
facebook
you know they get money from facebook
that's that's one of the so you're well
that's clear cut go for facebook yeah
you can say you make you mentioned lead
stories so we had we did a big piece on
lead stories i guess probably 2019 my
whole sense of timing is screwed up
because of covet uh it's like seems like
30 years in the last year and a half but
uh we did it and we slammed them they
denied everything we did yeah we said
about them but then right after they
launched their red and blue feed to show
that they were fact checking both sides
but here's the game that these that it's
not just them but that facebook and all
the companies play
when
they fact check somebody on the right
it's you know it goes gets scattered all
over facebook and attached to everything
that anybody posts about that but if
they do it for somebody left it doesn't
do that so if they fact check
uh you know some micro organization or
occupied democrats saying something
stupid because they're idiots uh you
know if they fact check them well then
they won't say oh by the way they were
actually citing something cnn did
they're not going to then attach that
fact check to cnn it just drops there
and so that's the way so what they've
set it up is it deliberately hurts
conservative organizations and anybody
who disagrees with the status quo which
i'm pretty sure is the people in this
room
yep i would say so
it's a broken system
i don't know what else to say we've been
dealing with with it for a long time and
i guess the challenge is it just shows
how dark things are continually getting
that we even move beyond this knowing
it's happening and nothing's changed
right we're now we're now at a period
where
we're we can't have discussions about
the science they tell us trust the
science and i'm like okay well a bunch
of scientists just came out
not those scientists
i'm like well
who am i supposed to trust that and why
dr fauci but faji's been wrong every
other day yeah well trust him
what about those doctors over there nope
all right i guess what about when fauci
outright you know got called out for oh
moving the goal post which we which in
civilized society we call lying through
his teeth but when when he did that or
when he lied about masking what about
when sanjay gupta is actually one of my
favorite little elements from from kovid
when
early march 2019 when sanjay or 2020
when sanjay gupta had a town hall at cnn
where they had about 60 some people
packed you know
shoulder to shoulder in the audience not
wearing masks when gupta comes out and
says
on air that masking is dangerous
now gupta said that yeah
then oh suddenly they decide that later
on masking is good all right i'm okay
i'm okay with them doing that if they
keep saying by the way you know i said
this this dumb thing before and keep
putting it out there but what happens is
all that stuff gets memory hold every
time fauci does something or gupta does
something or any of these people they
say something that's wrong or you know
later on proven wrong there's no there's
no accountability for them there's only
accountability for us thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time